James our producer in Kelly our
associate producers spend time combing
through the hating on Dave Twitter
section of the world and occasionally
pull up mean tweets to be read by me and
so we do a segment called Dave reads
mean tweets which we stole from somebody
like Jimmy Kimmel or somebody like that
does that that somebody that's cool so
but it is kind of funny and it's you
people are characters some of you so
frank says on Twitter
my wife was explaining what lint is to
our six-year-old and why she gave up
sweets immediately she said I want to
give up Dave Ramsey you could give up
Dave Ramsey for Lent that's good Matthew
seriously though having Dave Ramsey in
your zombie survivor group would be
awful quote enough about savings
accounts Dave there aren't no more banks
yeah I'm worried about being in your
zombie sir oh yeah I'm trying to work
with real-life zombies I think it's time
to come back around to the living land
of the living again Zooey says no I
don't want to listen to Dave Ramsey talk
sorry not sorry
well change the channel darling Kimmy
says Dave Ramsey Dave Ramsey's voice is
too smooth and it rubs me the wrong way
it's that is that not paradoxical or
contradictory I mean if it's just smooth
how would it rub you the wrong way
that's weird so I mean it's like if it
was rough it would do that that's fine
okay cute oh this one's great ray says
Dave Ramsey once makes me want to shove
three thousand needles in each of my
eyes this is the same kind of person
that burns their own neighborhood to
protest why are you putting needles in
your eyes three thousand of them because
of me so strange oh and the fun ones are
this if you don't know we're now in 33%
of high schools
with our foundations in personal finance
high school curriculum and that means
we've just graduated our two millionth
high school senior and so part of my
Twitter feed is this hilarious banter
back and forth with these high school
students sitting in class that
apparently have no idea that other
people can see Twitter other than them
and they use it like instant message or
something there so some of them are so
technologically inept now others are
very nice and say some nice things too
but this is a mean tweets segment so
we're not going to talk about those so
Serena is obviously one of those
students and I got in trouble when I
first started trashing me I thought they
were like adults trashing me and I would
mess with them on Twitter and then I got
like little teenagers got Twitter abused
because of me and I didn't mean then I
had to quit doing that cuz I found out I
was a kid as a kid I got this kid
Twitter killed so this is like a crashed
all right so Serena says Mr bland loves
talking about Dave Ramsey literally who
is Dave Ramsey there you go kara says
personal finance is listening to Dave
Ramsey for an hour and a half and I
don't think I can do it today I think
somebody's kept the class looking this
Alexandra I'm two minutes in and Dave
Ramsey makes me want to hang myself well
maybe you could tag team with the girl
with the 3,000 needles in her eyes since
you're into self destruction do two
listening today Ramsey that's great
Stacy says Dave Ramsey's great but you
should read about good debt versus bad
debt if you want to understand wealth
there you go
ken says why do evangelicals love Dave
Ramsey time to return to Sola scriptura
hash tag Jesus now I got to tell you
I've read the Bible most of my life my
adult life anyway and I've studied a lot
I am so dumb I did not know what that
meant i'll be--i'll be authentic and
just tell you the truth I had to go look
it up did you know what that meant
either we all know it solo scripture did
you did you had to look it up
no you you'd heard of it I'd heard of it
but I I think it just means the
scripture is the supreme rule that if
it's not in Scripture that all doctrine
should come from Scripture which sure so
how is that inconsistent with me I
didn't tell you to do something one
scriptural everything we do I mean we
often talk about what's in the Bible
when it says about money so that's weird
but I mean I guess guys like Ken they
probably don't have a car because cars
not in Scripture and you can't have a
bike either you got a walk-in it's not
in Scripture Oh in insurance it's not in
Scripture second hesitations covers
whole life verses term so kind of doofus
is this but he throws out throws out
stuff like Sola scriptura yeah so what
you say say it again
Twitter is not in Scripture and you're
using it ken there you go that's good
Kelly I like that that's even better
that's funny
Leslie fun fact Dave Ramsey has blocked
me on Twitter for criticism all that
happens a lot if you think I am on
Twitter in order to put up with your
crap you're confused I'll help you with
that
bok-bok-bok just like that I don't
hesitate and so you know you think
you're going to take me to task on
something on Twitter I don't know you
little round red egg person you don't
even have the guts to put like your real
name on there with all your digital
courage so blah and even if you do have
your name and your stuff on there and
you start cussing at me or you start
going you know you're an idiot and you
Indian you don't know what you're
talking about and you shouldn't need
this you shouldn't do that I'm not
taking a poll on Twitter you guys it's
not what it's for for me I'm using it to
communicate ideas to you and have some
conversations with you but it's not
where I it's not like I'm going to get
in some kind of debate with 140
characters with you and I don't even
know who you are
so you want to start that crap block
just like that I just block them and
thousands are blocked
thousands and you start cussing you
start dropping F bombs and stuff Twitter
feed blah you know
reading this stuff I don't want the crap
in my brain so you're done you're done
that's it so it you know Leslie I don't
want to bother you or anything but
you're really not that special I blocked
a lot of people it's a you're on a very
long list I just added the mute button
which is not as much fun as blocking
because they don't know you blocked them
then you just muted them so I'd rather
them no it's more fun to tell you you
got unfriended on Twitter well that's a
Facebook term I know all right last one
of the mean tweets reads Dave Ramsey
sounds like the evil bear off of Toy
Story 3 beste
got a southern accent I didn't know what
the bear sounded like that's pretty cool
yeah do kind of sound like that that's
pretty good that's actually funny sorta
and a weird mean sorta way Dave Ramsey
sounds like the evil bear off of Toy
Story 3 that was my goal so everyone
that has a southern accent sounds like
the Teva bear we story 3 yeah well there
you go folks
one of the more popular segments I have
no idea why but those were pretty good I
wouldn't call it there's a couple of
those or A's but they're mainly bees and
there's a few C's in there y'all were
really reaching there's not a lot of
good hate out there cuz I lost the
Rabanne oh yeah
hunt school gets going yeah when school
gets going we'll get we'll just do it
one devoted to high school yeah there
wasn't one or two on there this morning
but you probably could you can't read
those with all that those cuss words in
there so yeah I mean you kiss your
mother with that mouth jr. I mean really
nasty so yeah parents you ought to
follow your children's Twitter feeds
teachers you ought to follow your
students Twitter feeds you would
discover things about you that you had
no idea they say and you would discover
they I mean apparently uh Kara's
skipping class y'all didn't even know
she's skipping class smoking in the
girls room you know there you go so we
should have played that song to go that
y'all don't even know that you're not
old enough to smoking in the boys room
it wasn't girls room but it was Kara so
I changed it you it now yeah I'm not
going there
it's all about hating on me today so or
just keep it to me
just keep the hate on day this is the
day for NZ chef